I'm Harry crotteau I'm a chemist Nobel
Prize winner formerly at the University
of Sussex and now in florida state
university in Tallahassee Sir Harry
kroto was awarded the nobel prize in
chemistry in 1996 with Robert Kyle and
Richard Smalley for the discovery of c60
the molecule made up of 60 carbon atoms
but garnered fame for being shaped like
a soccer ball c60 was named
buckminsterfullerene or buckyballs in
tribute to the architects buckminster
fuller and his iconic geodesic domes the
discovery of buckyballs led to an
entirely new branch of chemistry the
science of fullerenes until then carbon
was only known to take on two forms one
was extremely hard diamond and the other
very soft but electrically conductive
graphite the new fullerene molecules and
their close relations carbon nanotubes
often exhibit both of these properties
and are already being tested in solar
cells nano circuits and drug delivery
systems carbon nanotubes have already
proven to be the strongest materials in
the world and promised exceptionally
light and versatile components
and now in a new chapter for fullerene
chemistry a team of astronomers using
NASA's Spitzer Space Telescope have
found the first evidence of buckyballs
in space 25 years of debate first
artificially created in a laboratory I
have two major interest to do a few more
research explorations things that still
interested in science I personally have
a major passion for leaving more so than
science and that's art and graphic
design and also get more involved in my
educational program trying to explore
the ways the Internet can be used more
effectively to help teachers teach
science better I have a mission to
ensure that you people understand
science and science is about asking
questions and curiosity and I'm prepared
to answer any question you throw at me
by visiting Nobel Prize dot orgs YouTube
channel you can send us your questions
wherever you are in the world using our
new google moderator interface you can
post a text or video question browse
other questions and vote on your
favorites Sir Harry croteau will answer
a selection of the most popular
questions the deadline for submissions
is the fourth of September 2010